غضب المصري حريه غضب المصري حريه حريه
حريه حريه حريه حريه حريه حريه حريه ولا
غزتنا الحريه لا غزتنا الحريه ولا غزتنا
الحريه يا غزتنا الحريه ويا حكومه مصريه
يا حكومه مصريه ويا حكومه مصريه يا حكومه
مصريه وكيف قبلتي هذا العار كيف قبلتي هذا
العار وشاركت هذا الحصار شارك في هذا
الحصار وعلى غز الابيه على غزه الابيه
وعلى غز العربيه سر الحصار لازم نكسر
الحصار وخلق المعبر اكبر عار وخلق المعبر
اكبر عار وخلق المعبر اكبر عار خلق المعبر
اكبر عار ونحنا بناخذ القرار واحنا بناخذ
القرار ولازم نكتار الحصار لازم نكسر
الحصار ولازم نكسر الحصار لازم نكسر
الحصار رغم البرد ورغم الجوع رغم البرد
ورغم الجوع وغزه بترفض الركوع غزه بترفض
الركوع وغزه بترفض الركوع غزه بترفض
الركوع قصف وجوع مع حصار قصف وجوع مع حصار
قصف وجوع مع حصار قصف وجوع مع حصار وشعب
بغزه ما بينهار شعب بغزه ما بينهار وشعب
بغزه ما بينهار شعب بغزه ما بينهار والخطه
جوع وتركيع والخطه جوع وتركيع والخطه جوع
وتركيع والخطه جوع وتركيع شعب بغزه ما
بيبيع شعب بغزه ما
بيبيع